hello everyone I'm Ilana welcome my
channel went today I'm pretty pumped to
be showing you guys some destiny to
forsaken content heads up I'm not
allowed to show you any of the cutscenes
from what you're about to see so if
there are weird cuts it's because I have
to get rid of those unfortunately but
yeah I got to play the game up at Bungie
which was kind of a dream come true it
was it was honestly pretty emotional
that I got to go to Bungie and it's just
halo stuff everywhere and I feel like
I've just put so many hours into Bungie
games throughout my life that getting to
go there was a really cool experience
but I was also very impressed with the
amount of content in forsaken we're
gonna be walking through the gameplay of
prison break mission it's very cool it's
very pretty and let's do it alright
cutscene has happened I will let Kate
and Petra explain what's going on so
they get because of prison riots so we
split up you take them out so this this
thoughts with like a lot of like running
through corridors giant explosions I
actually thought that it was a really
cool scripted moment that seems very
halo Esquivel honestly it's super pretty
as well and I think I'm mostly impressed
with the sound design I'm not using any
new weapons or anything like that in my
loadout so none of that is new the
gameplay feels you know regular old
destiny but that's certainly enjoying
and yeah you're basically going through
this this level while Kate kind of just
talk [ __ ] in your ear it's actually
pretty great but trying to prevent like
some kind of outbreak really really
nailed
they were so far away
I don't even know what just did that I
don't even know okay they're all trying
to figure it out it's not just me
I have already played through this than
I'm like wait what hey girl hey girl hey
you already on the lower decks security
Oh have you conveniently half closed
doors so I can't walk in there you sure
know how to make a video game actually
really enjoyed this fight um this pot is
like a full corridor of you fighting
drags and a few bigger enemies and it's
actually really fun because you kind of
dip between each side of the field and
then you like kind of pop out again I
know it's really interesting
[Music]
I just will never never get sick of that
a warlock supercharged Wow really mostly
whatever but doesn't it look pretty
ah why would you be any other cost and I
don't get it all these hunters what are
you missing out on cool fire swords we
talked about what that the music is also
how cool is that
I think that's Kate yeah I feel like
he's just like Deadpool but destiny he's
desta pool trademark that but yeah I
feel like this mission has a lot of
neatly scripted sequences that do make
it feel like the stories a lot more
impactful and any destiny fans will know
probably what happens in this mission I
won't spoil it for anyone who doesn't
even though they've been pretty like
kind of playing it fast and loose over
there at Bungie just drawing out spoils
all over the Internet and everyone's
really confused if you saw this is III
probably so what happened here but I
won't reiterate it too just in case
anyone doesn't know what happens but I
think there's a lot of emotional weight
in this in this mission and I think they
play it off really really really smartly
you guys have questions in the comments
oh I'm happy to answer them I can be
more specific down there
there are vocals in this track so I
think that was K that just fell off the
edge I want to do that this is one thing
drives me crazy in destiny it looks like
you should be able to shoot through gaps
you never can you can't like shoot
through pages most of the time I don't
know why I don't like it but I feel like
it looks like I can shoot through it if
I can put the end of the gun through
that I can shoot through their wine let
me get it
ah yes mega spawn of Cebu oh the other
dude was a part of a cult for this guy
and I'm trying to call for him petty
like bucks [ __ ] up on weekends you just
you just turn into smoke it's like you
just sort of bought it instead so much
for that cult so here we've broken into
the security area
solo comedy writing in here
[Music]
so many cult members in this prison oh
my god it's Scientology
let me go back to Kade naturally we jump
there like an idiot because walk
I like escape also how about Nathan
Fillion what a dude you guys see that
Uncharted short unrelated but man good
stuff also
techno music it like got all ETM up in
you it's I think the the variety of
music is so cool alright what's them all
out this is my second time seeing it and
I'm still just smiling like an idiot
security should be a terminal you can
use out on the catwalks oh thanks I
really appreciate the cover even though
everyone is already dead you spent that
whole time sitting in that room okay I
guess
he opened the door for me that's
actually pretty nice take it back okay
the church have a manual boat so this
part as he just alluded to
Cades that's controlling the turrets to
literally cover you while you look for
the terminal again cool and the music
Specter looking upbeat and triumphant
and he actually does dammit you know
sometimes there are NPCs that I have
like weapons if it looks like the
shooting that they don't actually
accomplish anything but I think he lets
you take the kills which is packs
very good well so there's a fly in here
you guys see a fly just flying past me
that's my bad
sorry about that
gotta skip ahead Sofia reference that
cutscene was like six minutes and epic
but maybe you leave now because you'll
hear some dialogue that might be spoiler
any stories if you're still here I
assume that you're fine with that but I
want to say that cutscene when you guys
see it is really really really good
it's like action movie esque dramatic
and cool and really well scripted I was
I was really impressed by that I'm
excited for everyone to see it and see
what everyone thinks of it but it's also
just again a thing that I'm so happy is
in destiny now this this it's close this
pot the game almost starts to turn into
like a survival horror sort of Oh at
least shows you that it could I'm just
caught myself on fire by that but at
least kind of like hints you that if it
wanted to do that it would be totally
possible it gets kind of dog when
discovering this new enemy and and what
they've been up to and how they exist in
something malicious is definitely in the
air and yeah definitely see this is like
kind of spooky right I think having the
Alam in the background just adds to it
it's also there's so much going on like
it's dark like you could you could make
this dead space this part just looks
like inside you guys haven't played
excited you play inside
I want the heavy ammo why can you just
get out of here so I can get that having
at my place just let me just thank you
thank you appreciate it
I'm yeah I love that there's gonna play
it again it's like I'm watching myself
play I'm watching my own gameplay
footage right now and I'm like just give
me the controller Ilana should give me
the controller it's no longer though
I'll be in Japan actually while you're
watching this you guys I am in Japan
I never very smartly placed slightly
broken door so you have to look at the
thing but you can't go through it but
yeah I'm in Japan right now I'm pre
recording this to edit on the flight
over to have up an embargo so you guys
can see it I thought about also doing
spider-man because I've been playing
that to boggle for that is tomorrow but
everything that I wanted to say about
spider-man I've kind of already said in
my spider-man bus's Ockham asylum or
akhom video from what I've played I
still feel very similarly to that hope
that that's not breaking above
it's just so pretty
you shoot him right in their faces I
find that gun gets me so bad I'm very
very bad at evading that weapon kicks my
foot throw more boys out of ourselves
that's not what we want so close to
being invisible but they just really
give themselves away with that weird
green smoke they just kind of explode
all over the place it's unfortunate I
love how obvious it is when I don't know
where to go I feel like you you so
clearly looking at this game play it's
like oh she lost cuz I'm like wait a
minute wait a minute this pot is like
Gears of War Z the emulsion wretches you
know just explode on you
again it's kind of spooky it's like
almost even makes me think of what the
dead I feel like my head is just one
giant series of things reminding me in
videogames that's mostly how I function
also i affiliate you can tell I'm
panicked in this gameplay like looking
around gets slightly more erratic I'm
like cleaning the walls like small
explody boys something just happened no
gates ghost without his ghost Kade
you're still here after I warned you
it's your own fault I'm not gonna
confirm won't deny anything cutscenes
are all still edited out respawning
restricted algaas yes a demented
abomination favorite
flawless start Alana
excellent execution
it feels good to be a warlock doesn't it
show those so wait I'm in front of green
screen right now I can actually do that
feels good doesn't know Ilana shadows so
yeah this is kind of the boss fight of
permission again doing it by myself it
did cause me a little bit of trouble but
I mostly just managed to hide behind the
stuff that I'm hiding mine right now
demented abomination is actually the
name of my favorite death metal band
and he down
you think all the other guys die when
he's down - yeah hold on Kate
we're coming we are the rest of it is
cutscenes that obviously I can't or
won't show you guys seriously you guys
seen that fly that's in here how do you
get flies out of your apartment
but really that is the basically the
first story mission in forsaken and I
really really liked it obviously huge
thanks to Activision for flying me up to
see Bungie which is like kind of a dream
come true to me it was it was really
cool being in that office and just
seeing all that stuff and thinking about
how much time I've put into Bungie games
throughout the course of my life and how
many genuinely incredible memories
Bungie games have given me and I'm
stoked to get back in to destiny a
little more with with the second
especially after everything I played
some of it I can't talk to you guys
about some of it I wasn't allowed to
CAPTCHA but it's looking pretty good
and yeah it's nice that I feel like
there's a lot of content that you'll be
able to play by yourself like the story
missions like this one and stuff that
you'll be able to do with other people I
feel like there's probably a pretty good
mix in there but I can't say much more
thank you guys for watching I hope you
enjoyed this little brief preview I'm
Alana
like I said I'm in Japan I don't know
when my next video will be up but we'll
see and I'll see you guys next time